congressional aides and visitors to the
house side of the capitol will face
arrest if they're not wearing masks
the head of the u.s capitol police
announced this week
in a wednesday letter to his officer
corps capitol police chief
thomas manger ordered that they enforced
the new mask guidelines across the
capitol complex
those new rules installed by the capitol
physician earlier in the week
includes a mask mandate on the house
side of the capitol and all house office
buildings
the new policy has been hammered by
house republicans who say it's merely an
effort
by speaker nancy pelosi to exert control
over half of the capital
still she has law enforcement now on her
side
i think what's interesting about all of
this is that politicians
always like to paint winston churchill
was famous for painting same thing with
dwight eisenhower
george w bush also tried with much more
limited success
but the thing is that those politicians
had painting as a pastime
this certainly seems like painting as a
pass through
and what's frustrating about the entire
setup that we're sort of being asked to
accept
um you know that it's somehow above
board is that the anonymity
actually puts a premium on this art
because you're gonna have
the uh the white house uh says that
they've given this new system it's
blessing
this art dealer who seems to be a shady
character to begin with
they're going to do everything they can
to keep this anonymous so that we don't
know
who is shelling out you know tens of
thousands of dollars to
support hunter biden's burgeoning art
career
say what you will about trump hotel in
washington dc
as corrupt as it was uh the difference
was that
oftentimes you could go there and you
could actually see
who was doing their best to sort of uh
backhandedly grease the palm of the
former administration
this is actually even worse yeah i mean
the political discourse is interesting
because i think we often look to the
president
uh to solve problems you know they're
obviously the largest and tallest
political figure in the country
but to a large extent criminal justice
is a state and local issue right it's
administered
by municipalities most people who are in
jail or in prison are in
state prisons or local presence
or or they're in jail or waiting for
trial uh
the federal government has a role to
play for sure but i do think that we
tend to oversell overplay that role
um the primary task that they that they
would have
would be one they have the obviously the
federal
if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his face off
explaining to us why trump really won
the election again
inspectors every state
almost every approved this was thrown
away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out wait
he's saying there was a dead person
in the envelope rudy's about to have
actual
drops of sweat coming off of his brow i
mean is this a normal amount i don't
know how hot it is in the room but this
something seems
very wrong here i'll be in the lawsuit
that comes out duty's melting
arizona is a k is a state that we're
looking at very very carefully
strongly looking at it i would say we're
probably i assume
she's working if she's working for them
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time you should have had
the time and energy to go look for them
[Music]
that's your job like it's my job to
defend the president
i don't represent the president it's
lane michigan
wisconsin is he bleeding did you see is
he bleeding from his ear
what on earth was that
[Music]
[Music]
he's gotta get off the stage and there
are other aspects of this fraud
on the morning of development someone's
gotta get him a napkin they were gonna
count
the these this new kind of bat i've
never seen anything like this
what on earth it's getting onto his
shirt now she again and wisconsin any
jury would accept
because they heard this evidence that
somebody had this plan this is insane
maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sapped from an oak tree or
a maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup
should the city describe that to you oh
my god it's all over his
face he's gonna need a towel
dealing with evidence i don't know guys
it's sounding like trump won
isn't it based on this
we are amazing welcome to
to the uh fall estate youtube live i'm
jessalyn peterson
apologize for the late start but we are
black and black people are late
we start our cp time i'm glad you're
here you love me
i don't really know you do you have to
know me to love me yeah well i love you
thank you uh are you surprised not
really were you surprised that i threw
you off the radio show
not really one of these i'm concerned
about you being a progressive
is that me specifically or all
progressives all men
men only men only men progressive women
that don't concern
it's normal normal abnormal for women to
be progressive
interesting oh but it's abnormal for a
man to be a liberal or progressive
it's a sign of being a beta male i
didn't know because real men
are conservative if i became
conservative
would i no longer be beta
something to think about do you find
that it's difficult for young men
men in your age group to find good women
to date
not at all all right why don't you date
men i'm not attracted to men
oh god what would you consider it might
be a man would you think of it as a man
it would i think of it as a man right
it's a person right i don't say right
it's a female
the children are the lie the liberal
media the democratic party the writer
republicans the double trumpers
okay uh so like everybody but trump the
hashtag
movement plus you sound mentally off you
know like
like the likes was all but nobody was
home you're making assessments of who's
mentally off on
tv but that's how evil the children on
the left are they'll destroy you
to get what they want and that's power
and wealth i'm curious
if they're so powerful the children of
the law they're not powerful
oh that's what they want i think they
will destroy you they will they'll
destroy you they'll try to destroy it oh
okay to get power and well
do you agree with that no no bring that
up the reason was you've called me a
girly man so many times
remember that we talked about weak oh
okay that's because it's not because i
think you
that i'm gay right got it glad we
clarified you know a lot of people are
sexually assaulted and raped
and they don't come forward and the
reason why they don't
you don't believe that that's a made-up
lie too oh who made that up the children
are the laughs
i should i'm sure of their lives i
should have known they're doing it
because they hate men
oh and they especially hate straight
white conservative christian men of
power
if it wasn't for them america would be
associated
society by getting rid of jobs many
people emotionally took care of people
about getting into
full-time jobs and they had to work two
part-time jobs in order to survive so
you don't even understand the talking
points arrest three obama phones
that's social socialism but you're not
answering a question that's the answer
but i don't like the answer you don't
understand the question
i think i understand it uh what is it
about the questions that's difficult for
you
do you would you david pacman believe it
just because she said it i liked how you
had to check what
my last name was there i would leave it
enough to investigate it yeah
give me just a yes i'm black and slow so
give me a simple yes or no
your friends are watching right now i
hope so and they were watching because
they thought you're gonna keep my butt
so you gotta live up to it i found out
this was a debate today
would you believe it are these really
the most important topics for you
absolutely okay are there others that
are more important for you yeah like
what's up our economic system wealth
inequality healthcare
geopolitics nuclear disarmament climate
change and the black people go into a
trance
and they go in and then you yeah they
they reach for the d
while eating chicken i guarantee you if
they went now
and voted for and asked them to vote for
it they'll go with the homosexuals i
hope so and the democratic party
also they have been morally bankrupt
well i don't know radical homosexuals
have gotten in there they corrupt the
churches
is there anything else not that i can
think of that's it yeah
amazing people coming from [ __ ]
countries and we don't have no idea who
crossing the borders
uh we can have bin laden folks come in i
think we just disagree
amazing um
it's crazy to disagree isn't it is that
a good thing that the president has
done what did he do when he buy jobs how
it doesn't matter how he's brought them
back is that a good thing if you're
going to claim he did it you have to
explain how is that a good thing that
happened
it talked about there are too many jobs
the question is what did he do to bring
the
can jobs identify what he did i just
told you man how do you know he did it
this is a good thing that he did in that
jobs are good i'm asking you what trump
did what are you saying yesterday
what is a man i'm sorry what is a man
i do politics not dictionary are you a
man love what is love
all right guys so we i can't take any
more of it and we have too much to talk
about to continue with the silliness
welcome everybody at the top of the hour
we're gonna hear from the president
i don't even have to tell you who it is
i you know who the president is
obviously
and uh it is going to be about vaccines
and masks
now you may or may not know it is usa
number one
in new coronavirus cases okay let's look
at
the data from yesterday
yesterday new cases oh whoops this is
hold on this is just the u.s
yesterday new cases the usa
nearly doubling the second country
84 000 new cases in the united states
now fortunately so far
the deaths aren't exploding the way
cases are
and we're hoping vaccination has a big
part to do with that
but we have a lot of people in this
country who do not want to get
vaccinated
and as a result it is rumored that today
joe biden is going to announce
a 100 dollar incentive no i'm sorry he's
not going to announce it
he's going to encourage states to do a
100 incentive for new vaccination
now i think at any cost we've got to get
people vaccinated
i do understand that you're gonna by
adding the
the hundred bucks now you're rewarding
the people
who did the wrong thing and didn't yet
get vaccinated
right okay yeah so um i mean you know
if you wanted to make it retroactive for
everybody
whatever i just want to get people
vaccinated i don't need the hundred
bucks i don't care
but um there is something to that new
york city has put in place a hundred
dollar
um debit card basically you get a
hundred dollar debit card
when you get vaccinated now when you get
your first dose and joe biden reportedly
will be recommending that states put
that in place
so we are going to hear that at the top
of the hour there may be new mass
guidelines etc now many of you have
asked
david sir are you still going to travel
next week
even with what is going on and the
answer is yes and
and why because everything i booked is
non-refundable that's basically why
no i mean listen first of all um as some
of you know
i'm going to be going to uh to spain and
spain actually seems to be on the
decline
from delta and when you consider
or at least peaked we're still climbing
when you consider
that the testing reflects people who
were incubating the virus about eight
days ago
it's possible actually that the
situation's much better in spain than
the united states but but it's sort of
i mean yeah it looks crazy but you know
compared to what's going on here
which is just it's like vertical uh wait
a second where is it
the average is going straight up whereas
in spain at least it seems to have
leveled off
who the hell knows you know i was
speaking to my brother yesterday and he
was saying
listen unless you're not going to travel
for two years
right now i'm in the thick of the
immunity because it's only been six
months since my second dose
and i'm gonna wear the mask and i'm
gonna be outside who the hell knows
who the hell knows but it seems like
things are sort of going better in spain
than they're going here so yeah
i still plan to travel and uh
who the hell knows anyway that's that's
what's going to be going on we're going
to have some
great guest hosts by the way farron
cousins of
farron balanced and ring of fire is
going to be doing a little bit of
guest hosting for me um
jesse dollamore is going to be doing
some guest hosting i think the audience
is going to enjoy
very strongly being introduced to jesse
dallimore
um that'll be at the very end of next
week next friday
and then the week after from the
standpoint of
calendar and uh i think people will
oh my god where is this cable coming
from what is going on here
this cable just came out of nowhere it's
now wrapped around my arm
okay um yeah anyway i think people will
enjoy it and then i'll be back and we'll
hold
we're holding back a few clips from this
week and next week
so there will still be some new content
published to facebook and
uh youtube it's all gonna be crazy okay
guys let's move on
um i'm being attacked by my set it's
crazy actually
robert sends today's first super chat
and says david the senate just passed
capital security bill 980 why would
republicans vote for a bill to protect
themselves from peaceful tours and lob
fest
yeah i guess mo brooks was wearing body
armor on january 6th
which is weird if there's no risk to
anybody
chakaseki says david heard from a
credible source that marjorie taylor
green
is definitely not crazy and matt gates
is not a pedophile please advise yeah
that's what i'm hearing from them anyway
why don't you see super chats the window
over there
the first two or three are just above i
just had to do it that way because
otherwise later it causes a problem
i believe with the next super chat
you're gonna start seeing them on
screen okay i have so many things to go
over with you guys
first of all i think i finally have
my plasma drops working let's test it
convalescent plasma donate plasma today
please
donate plasma yep beautiful so we've got
those working for some reason we were
having
technical issues um with those but we've
got them
convalescent plasma so that's good um
what else do i have oh spencer says
david what's your favorite latin drum
pattern to play much love from utah
i don't know that i have a favorite um
but let me tell you guys one of the best
books
okay this is such a strong book right
here
uh hold on a second
anybody wanting to learn some of those
some of those rhythms the best drum book
people are gonna go crazy i expect a run
on this book
just from me mentioning it right now
from all the drummers in the audience
uh here it is oh no what a slow website
this is the book right here afro cuban
rhythms for drum set
by i believe it's by the great uh bob
wiener yep frank
maliby and bob weiner my old drum
teacher used to take lessons with bob
weiner this is a
absolutely perfect perfect book so for
people i don't know
how many people this applies to in the
audience but if you're looking to learn
afro-cuban rhythms to drum for drum set
that's the that's the book to get okay i
want to say thanks to
sib jenkinson who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code
my hipaa and his new member number one
because everything is vaccine related
and
this new hipaa thing is the new talking
point the coupon code myhipa
saves you 70 on my website i also want
to say thanks to endy's
deeper shades of house lee lee
for signing up via twitch prime numbers
two three
and four very much appreciate that
other super chats coming in at this
point oh wait hold on
hey david what are your thoughts on
possible attacks in august from the
extreme right yeah i
i think it's conceivable that we will
see violence from the right in august
at this point pfizer should pay people's
mortgages maybe they will then will get
more vaccinated
yeah why not a house collapsed into the
ocean in argentina i didn't hear about
that but i'm sorry to hear it
sir there have been no live urgent
streams lately is it because things are
more boring with biden in office no
we'll do some urgent
we'll do some urgent soon jacob ratner
says sir have you or will you read i
alone can fix it it's pretty eye-opening
i would like to read it i have a stack
of books my books are stacked to high
heaven right now so we'll see if i can
get to it
um here's an interesting question what
is your standpoint on the standpoint of
stand pointing
i have been unable to conclude my
standpoint without this kind of stand
pointing
on deck that's a great question um
in fact i think i have something related
to that
hold on where is it one of the wettest
we've ever seen
from the standpoint of water water water
um also thank you to rich yankee
i wonder if that's a real name rich
yankee has signed up on my website
i appreciate that new member number five
um thanks very much
and let us continue okay a couple of
other things to go over with you guys
um this is just would i be allowed to
just show you
something fun and take a break from the
fact that we have really serious things
going on
would we be allowed for one comedic
element just as a brief thing
i know some people get you know mad when
when i'm just doing
non-serious things sephie
sefer hyde okay this is one of my
absolute
favorite channels on youtube this is
xiaoma nyc
this is a i believe just like you know
just a jewish guy like me
who is proficient in mandarin as well as
other languages
and i absolutely love this guy's channel
it's one of my favorite favorite
channels
and he does this thing where he sets up
different pranks
and here's one where he and two of his
friends who also speak
mandarin they get into an argument in
mandarin on the street in chinatown
about the subway
and everybody around it's it's just
beautifully executed let's take a look
gotta go find out where the uh the
subway is now guys
huh do you guys know where the subway is
uh
61 6162 6162 yeah
okay so i just keep i just keep walking
that way yeah
oh the bus subway card
uh yeah that works on the bus though i'm
actually i'm not sure if i have that
hold on
but the buses are coming in like nine
minutes
[Music]
starting with the english bait is
perfect it is per you have to start with
the english
that really is what it's all based on
then a third guy shows up
yeah he said he said the same thing he
said the same thing yeah
over there like the switching to english
only talk to the only to talk to the
chinese guys is absolutely perfect
all right okay thanks guys thanks guys
cheers
thank you guys
hi anyway that's it's just absolutely
we'll we'll do one more what is what is
this one
cookie what cooking
i don't know why he has to act like such
a doofus like just because you don't
speak mandarin doesn't mean you're an
idiot about food you know but it's still
funnier it's fun
part of the whole thing oh wow look it's
like
huge
no i actually don't know why this
woman's speaking spanish to him that
actually is confusing to me i don't even
i don't i don't even understand that
it's funny because like part of what's
implicit i think part of what's funny is
they're not only acting like they don't
speak mandarin they're acting like they
don't understand how food works you know
like just be
you most people would be like oh yeah
you got to cook the vegetables some
vegetables are tough when you don't cook
them so you gotta
but like he's just pretending not to
know to know anything anyway so that's
one of my favorite youtube channels
right now that's xiaomi
nyc people want a little bit of uh
comedic comedic relief i like that um
let's look at a couple of other
super chats coming in um
i can't wait to see your take on
senators being denied entry to the dc
detention center oh
okay i actually have that i have that
ready i actually prepare for these
streams i know it's insane
to think but i'm actually this is what
happens with preparation i had that here
it's not senators it's actually members
of congress
uh cut radical republican congress
people
marjorie taylor gangrene louis gomer
and matt gates tried to go to a prison
facility holding january 6th
um terrorists and they were denied entry
why well because you can't just show up
and go in
and now even the context here is crazy
these members of congress are upset
about how the terrorists are being
treated
okay that's their problem that's what
they want to investigate why are the the
accused being treated so poorly
so anyway they were denied entry check
this out trespassing by attempting to
come
into this correctional facility on
whether or not
to fund you at what level and we're
trespassing
i understand that my gosh the government
is upside down
you right now are obstructing entrance
into this facility that's the way people
like her you're obstructing her we won't
have straight obstruct
she wants to abstract man she can't get
any word right
now that's what i'm doing
all right so anyway yeah they were they
were denied access
um and then afterwards they defiantly
unmasked and probably said things that
are really dumb
the supervisor came down was standing
right here
and turned her back on me the other one
says she won't talk how dare she
anymore that we're trespassers she's not
saying more than that
we have turned a corner we're in
totalitarian marxist territory
it is exact what marks actually people
may not know mark's
marxian uh teachings but um one of the
big things marx wrote about was
um that the first thing marx would do if
given control of a country
is not allow members of congress to go
whenever the hell they want anywhere in
a prison or a jail
that was like the main thing with marx
and it was like a big big thing just
control over
whether elected officials can go to
prisons so that's uh that was earlier
today
i mean just an absolute and complete
mess
and yeah totalitarian has lost all
meaning at this point data
mar all of this stuff um also
like buildings are communist
that's another thing just like a
building it's just extremely communistic
to have a building
jay harper says david sir i just started
reading again thank you for the advice
i'm reading rich dad poor dad and it's
great
yeah i wouldn't read rich dad poor dad
when i was 14 i read rich dad poor dad
then i realized it's of no value
whatsoever
um i would not read rich dad poor dad if
you want to read
some uh oh hold on a second what's going
on here
um i will give you some better personal
finance books to read if you want
rich dad poor dad it's just a commercial
enterprise it's of no value
by the way the thing you're going to
learn by reading good personal finance
books
is you don't need to learn very much
it's low-cost index funds
asset allocation save and
live within your means that like that's
the whole thing okay let me give you
some good personal finance books
from my library here
um hold on i'm just looking up uh
let's see yeah i know i mean i don't
want to hate
just rich dad poor dad it's not good
it's not good i've read five
six of the books and it's not you're
wasting your time with it
um okay
certainly millionaire next door that's a
good one
um
man it's been so long since i'm going
through my amazon order history
and i guess i haven't ordered these for
a while but
oh my god i apologize this i guess i
should just put a list together
yeah i don't even i'm sorry i don't have
the list there so there's a whole bunch
of books i could recommend on personal
finance
but um
yeah okay all right let's move i'll get
back to that at some other point in time
great that you're reading though that i
love that i absolutely love
thanks to david chadman who has now been
subscribed on twitch for 22 months
your new member number six today i also
want to say thanks to real time fan
donboy uk new members 7
and 8. if you are here
and you want to say yes to vaccination
you want to say yes to ending the
pandemic and you want to say
no to stupid talking points about hipaa
the best thing you could do right now
for everybody including for the world
is to get a membership on my website and
to use the code myhipa
now the only thing is you have to spell
it correctly
there's people spelling it with two eyes
that's wrong
there's people spelling it with two p's
that's
giga wrong it's h-i-p-a-a
you must spell it correctly for it to
work also 3hs at the beginning is wrong
it's all you have to spell it correctly
and i will thank everybody
already said thanks to rich yankee and
sib jenkinson who signed up
very much appreciate that okay um i
purpose the nih create the hipaa hippo
similar to how parks have smokey bear
sure okay
david andrew caligan did undercover
reporting at q anon i'd love to see your
reaction oh okay that sounds actually
interesting
let's see this i want to look at very
closely
uh cue conference
let's see i've kind of been searching
for the truth my whole life
and one time i just came across a video
that
was about biden and kamala harris and
clinton kamala kamala obama
they are satan worshipers satanists
they're satan worshippers
100 and i couldn't wait to tell my
family
and they just go they just said you're
crazy trump's
the worst how does that make you feel
sad i cry all the time
what is wrong with this woman what is
her medical condition
something's weird about this
but i just keep praying that's all i do
i just keep praying and asking god to
open
their eyes i have a beautiful family
they're just blind
which family member do you miss the most
probably my baby sister i told her we're
in a spiritual warfare this is between
good and evil and she rolled her eyes
what was her name meg we go and have
wine together and
lunch together and it's gone
[Music]
you wish you had never stumbled upon
once you learn you don't turn back i
know what god wants of us and what jesus
wants and it's what trump wants
and it's what the it's like q trump and
jesus seem to be very much on the same
page it's interesting
patriots want i would never turn back
no matter how many of my family i lose
[Music]
three times disabled permanently
disabled on facebook
censored permanently suspended why is
she screaming
they don't like my q plaque they don't
like my q mobile
well whoa whoa did you guys see that
what was that
well permanently disabled on facebook
censored
permanently suspended they don't like my
q flag
they don't hold the line cue patriot the
best is yet to come
i prefer dangerous liberty to peaceful
servitude
something about mom trump jfk junior
2021
wow i like my q-mobile and they're sure
they all don't like me in my cue patriot
costume
where we go one we go on you know this
is the type of thing where i would i
would be interested in like uh having a
psychiatrist maybe dr k
or someone on like how do i say this
is this like is this even political or
like if that woman went to dr k
would he just say you need
antipsychotics and it's like that's just
a medication
situation what would a psychiatrist say
about it i didn't say the m word anymore
right what the m word it's a it's a
dirty word it's
uh now i have my own words
instead of the words that i know the
algorithms are going to shut me down can
you tell us what words you use for which
we're not going to shut he's being
algorithmically shut down
uh mask the face diaper vaccine
the jokey pokey and electron fraud the
obvious fraud see people don't
understand
everything that we've learned from day
one
has been a lie everything we never on
the moon
no i don't think the hitler situation is
as bad as they said it was either that
was the rothschilds that was the
rockefellers
it was the jews guys the rothschilds did
a not that bad holocaust not hitler
those are naughty words
naughty naughty social media i got
that that's n-o-u-g-h-r-d-i-e-e-e-e-e
that's nordy forever on facebook
you're watching channel 5. after a
hectic few weeks on the road
covering events like the pickup artist
boot camp in las vegas
back open baby it's make out time
women love guys like this
[Applause]
and creating my first solo documentary
about two twins in marin city california
we've been anywhere and on a [ __ ]
what language was that
i decided to dive back into the world of
right-wing politics
that's when i discovered the god and
country patriot roundup a three-day
event in dallas which cost three
thousand dollars
okay let's get back to that because i
did have some other material
shockingly if you can believe it i did
have other material to go over with you
guys today
um let me let me quickly say thank you
to patricia goss who just signed up with
the coupon code myhipa
also lauren simanco signing up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
myhipa
um oh okay also thanks to ruttenberg
harry kratos aureon for signing up via
twitch numbers
11 12 and 13. and uh i
i do very much appreciate that um
do you so we had this is like a peek
behind the curtain we've already filmed
the the viewer calls that are going to
be on tomorrow's podcast three of them
are really crazy one is from a kid
who a kid a guy whose dad died of covid
and his mom still won't get vaccinated
another is from
a guy who's too afraid of a nuclear bomb
to go out of his house and another is
from a 17 year old whose parents won't
let him get vaccinated
are you guys interested in
previewing any of those
um wait 729
oh wait a second
oh i don't think they've been uploaded
yet
oh hold on a second i don't know that i
actually have them
oh okay we'll have to go back actually
yeah sorry
i don't actually have them ready i don't
have them ready yet okay
anyway it tomorrow it's a crazy it's a
crazy show
it's a crazy crazy show tomorrow um
i'll see if we can get them i'll see if
we can get them let's do a few other
super chats
david there was a story about a colored
woman
what it seems like this person's
referring to
the mayor of buffalo as a colored woman
unironically
i gotta get away from that guys i'm
sorry why would you want three other
walls on a building just build one
big long wall if you're after political
comedy check out boris johnson trying to
open an umbrella
yeah i actually tweeted about that um
it's pretty funny here it is
any moment now we'll be celebrating with
the fly past
of the national police air service so
we'll just wait
a moment on them
honestly one of my favorite things is
when umbrellas reverse
[Laughter]
oh man i actually have um
i actually have on my instagram an
instance of that happening to me
it's really far back let me see if i can
find it
oh here it is look this thi i actually
posted this ones
it spontaneously fixed itself
[Laughter]
oh man that is the best
okay all right anyway it's not just
right wingers that seem to have that
happen to them and
it could happen to the best of us it
really can um
i want to say thanks to matthew masada
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code myhipa
and his new member number 14 today also
thanks to
90s nba fan as well as uncle boobs
for subscribing via twitch prime
that was on my instagram guys not my
channel that's david.pacman on instagram
matt b says why does the right complain
so much about the actions that are
proven to get us out of the pandemic
it's like complaining about your house
being on fire
then yelling at the fire department
showing up i agree
becoming a member would violate my hipaa
rights
i agree which is why you should do it
sir i got a third shot on tuesday jay
and jay
i received moderna in january
i've not heard of anybody doing that
i've heard of people who originally got
j
and j going out and getting the mrna but
i have not heard of the reverse pedro
but it's it's interesting
i would i don't know what doctors say
about that what's your standpoint on
yard signs i'm against them completely
against them
sir do you have a segment on how kamala
harris can boost her approval rating
um i don't maybe i will put one together
i don't have any ideas offhand
jeffrey says amelia pond and chris
frederick to
answer your question the woman who won
the mayoral in buffalo while i can't
remember her name she is black
what on earth is going on
where do you find this stuff david and
how do you keep your sanity
two questions i don't want to answer
david have you seen the video of cuomo
interviewing an anti-vaxx restaurant
owner
yes i have that ready as well let's go
right to it i prepared everything for
you guys
let's get to it this is a guy who
requires
proof of being unvaccinated to go to a
restaurant i don't know how you prove a
negative
you really don't want people to not get
vaccinated so they can come to your
restaurant
that's a good that's a good question uh
you're a smart guy
it's an iq test and like i say to people
when they ask me
if they're so blinded uh with you know
with their rage
and their hate i tell them you know what
if you still don't understand it
uh maybe we should put up a sign up that
says you're too stupid to come into the
restaurant i mean it's very simple
just like you said i think you figured
it out am i right
i don't even know what you're saying
right now tell me
[Laughter]
oh man this this is just amazing
i'm saying we're making a point and so
you answer the question
so you haven't been vaccinated nobody in
your family's been vaccinated
if i answer that are you going to answer
that when i ask you yeah sure
ask me whatever you want now answer my
question
i'm not accident are you i am how about
your your parents
uh your your wife your kids you were
hesitant
no i got vaccinated i'm not i'm going to
ask you to say i'm going to ask you the
same thing is that all right yeah go
ahead
are you no is your family vaccinated
yes see what you're not getting what
you're not getting you're
you're failing the iq test what is it i
don't even understand what the question
is
i mean i understand i understand it is
are you vaccinated and he said yeah
we're not missing biden are we now okay
i don't want to miss bite you're not
getting
which i expected um what you're not
getting
is that uh this is not this is not an
anti-vaccine
stand it's a pro-freedom stand that's
what you're not getting
what is the difference when you are
ignoring
the science that suggests that if you
get vaccinated you protect yourself you
protect the people around you
and you help us get out of this pandemic
a little bit faster
so what's next then are we all going to
lock ourselves in our homes
oh that's why we get vaccinated so we
don't have to stay home
whenever there's a lot of flu outbreak
or or there's an outbreak of a cold
calm and cold or we can lock ourselves
inside our homes we're suggesting that
moon suit i mean where does it end it
ends with you getting the vaccine so
that this
virus doesn't keep replica doesn't i
gave you a chance to make the case
i wish you well i hope your family stays
safe i made my case you didn't have much
to say you didn't have much to say i
mean
honestly you sound like an idiot so
there's not much to say but tony good
luck
so do you yeah there's actually more
clips
um what is this guy's name even tony
roman okay
cuomo tony roman there were other clips
that
that had other elements oh this okay
okay
and uh you know maybe the conversation
should really be between me and your
brother
that's what i'm thinking why would a
california restaurant owner speak to the
governor of new york that doesn't even
make sense
maybe so you're pro-freedom but people
can't wear masks tony it doesn't make
sense it really doesn't i gave you a
chance to make the case
i wish you well i hope your family stays
safe i made my case you didn't have much
to say you didn't have much to say i
mean
honestly you sound like an idiot so
there's not much to say but tony good
luck with it
see you and so do you yeah i thought
only for having you on the show
[Laughter]
oh man that is rich um
all right let's see if this let's see if
there's any other clips here
um so we looked at the one that's 213.
yeah it's a bizarre interview um
let's see if this is a different clip
i'm throw freedom
anti-tyranny okay and you know maybe the
conversation should really be
between me and your brother okay that's
what i'm thinking that again
um it's brilliant writing yeah to write
in this character at this point in time
all right yeah so that that's wild it
was a wild wild interview
and what's really funny oh actually that
would be another thing to look at
that guy i guess felt it went so well
that he went on laura ingram's show to
talk about how well it went
um let me see here okay
you have vaccine wait a second where was
it
uh maybe aaron rupar posted it was like
the guy was acting like it was just
incredibly cool what he did
um see if we can find it
not here
no wasn't there was it acen tarabi who
posted it
it was it was like a weird victory oh
here it is uh
with a little chris cuomo on cnn and
you'll see him bail out
uh you know as soon as it got heated um
like the coward that he is right so i'm
saying we're making a point
yeah anyway and so you answered the
question
so you haven't been vaccinated nobody in
your family's been vaccinated if i
answer that are
you going to answer that when i ask you
yeah sure ask me whatever you want
now answer my question i'm not
vaccinated
are you i am how about your your parents
uh your your wife your kids you were
hesitant
no i got vaccinated i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna ask you to say i'm gonna ask
you the same thing is that all right
yeah go ahead
how's your no is your family vaccinated
yes see what you're not getting what
you're not getting you're
you're failing the iq test what you're
not getting
i mean where does it end it ends with
you getting the vaccine so that this
virus doesn't keep replicating and
creating variants
that we need to find ways to back the
whole reason this is happening is
because people
won't protect themselves tony i mean
what are you thinking
then why did you leave your house when
when you had coveted i mean you had it
and you left your house i mean it's been
documented first of all it has been
documented
my ass it's been documented i
quarantined
i went out my wife got accosted by
somebody i don't know man
and i i know you don't know so i'm
trying to help you the science is clear
tony
i don't want you to get sick the way i
was science is clear
oh you care about me all of a sudden huh
enough to have you on the show because i
don't like people how could this guy
possibly be running a successful
restaurant that's shocking
making bad decisions for themselves and
their family i was hoping it was a
little bit of a stunt
oh you have the freedom not to take the
vaccine i just don't know why you think
it's a good move
maybe maybe we should ask your brother
about
protecting people right look that's his
job and if he doesn't do it well people
won't vote for a whole new can of worms
but don't look tony okay how is that
even relevant you know it's like
what how is that even related it's it's
bizarre i don't know if you know me too
well i'm not sure
i stand is not a political family stay
safe
i made my case you didn't have much to
say you didn't have money all right
anyway
so yeah that was a bizarre bizarre whole
thing i don't even know what to make of
it
deflect distract yes exactly betty
you're exactly right
thanks to turtle 1984 for the twitch
prime subscription
number 17. you can go to twit i think
it's twitch.tv
prime right have they set something up
now where it's easy to set this up
twitch.tv prime if you have an amazon
prime account you want to link it to
twitch exactly
i want to say thanks also to ben
ruttenberg who just signed up on my
website with the code myhipa
clara ivanov just signed up on my
website with the coupon code
myhipa and amy browning who just signed
up at joinpakman.com with the coupon
code
myhipa numbers 18 19
and 20. as we stand by here i did
hesitate there on naming that last
person which means it may not be true i
guess according to that dude
um let's see what else we've got
david sorry if i confused you forget
about the other previous chats all
together all right i will jeffrey thank
you
i apologize to you david fellow drummer
in mississippi i want you to know
there's a large
and growing population of progressives
here give us time
great to hear forget all previous super
chats
i just wanted to know from your
perspective the difference between a
liberal a progressive and a socialist oh
my god
uh we uh jeffrey i couldn't even begin
to do that right now
um but we actually do have a long-form
explainer coming out
about socialist communist and social
democrat i think you'll enjoy it
david sir i got kovid was vaccinated
then just got coveted again also by
reading this you violated hipaa
much love from florida meow i don't know
what of any of that is true
i have no idea if any of that is even
true
uh all right let's do a couple of
voicemails and see if i have my
voicemail
uh fixed at this point in time let's
listen hi david my name is mark i'm
calling from toronto uh in canada
uh first time i've reached out to you uh
i've been listening to your show
for a little while now and and i became
a member a few months back
i really really love the work that you
do and uh
um i wish we had something like this
like your show in canada
if we do i'm not aware of it uh but
truth be told
american politics are infinitely more
interesting than canadian politics so
there you are
in any case i'm listening to your bonus
show from uh
july uh six and i'm always a day behind
cause i listen the next morning uh when
i'm
getting ready for work and uh you and
pat were talking about
uh all of the emails you got complaining
about your summer vacation
and i was one of those people who was
confused by your summer vacation and i
think i might
have a an inkling as to why so i thought
i might share it with you
since i'm already a member when i listen
to your show okay all right this is very
technical stuff okay
so we'll we'll look at that uh we'll
look at that pretty strongly let's see
hey david how's it going this is ron out
in hawaii
uh quick question that you might be able
to
comment on what if what do you think
would happen
if a republican proposed
changing the name of the republican
party
to the party of trump uh this is i mean
i have no idea
i have no idea let's um let's continue
hey david it's jared from honolulu uh
aloha
just wanted to point out hey so mike
lindell says august 13th
that falls on a friday this year friday
the 13th from screen statement
hey you guys want to know something i
was hesitant about whether to even tease
this
but um mike lindell scheduled to be on
the program next week
and uh i mean there's a very good chance
they look up
my show and they cancel it but mike
lindelos
i am scheduled to do a full interview
there have been no limitations even
placed
mike lindell scheduled to be on and i'm
gonna ask him
sir the first time i came across you
you were at the white house saying trump
was a gift from god
what sign did god give you that trump
was his gift to you
um that will be my first question
and then we'll see so it may get
cancelled i wasn't necessarily going to
tease it but it's it's all
it's pretty funny it's pretty funny um
all right let's listen to a couple of
other super chats i mean
voicemails
i was about to get upset that you didn't
like the pledge of allegiance
and i thought well what is the legion so
i looked up the word allegiance and then
that didn't make me happy and then
you know i i started reiterating the
words of the pledge of
allegiance to myself and i thought you
know what there's nothing wrong with an
allegiance
to this guy is drunk yeah
the people of america so why don't we
just
change the words we could take out god
and okay then he called back right away
what i don't understand is we live in a
country with a political system set up
to
to pretty much do as little as possible
because the democrats have the
uh they so that goes on for like three
uh three full minutes
um
let's see what else we got hey david
i just couldn't wait the show is playing
in the background which is a classic for
voicemails
uh send a message to you but you've got
to see this
quick uh it's you gotta hear it it's the
audio
the interview of the book only i can fix
this with the two
reporters the whole
audio tape of trump
he's talking about what is going on i
just heard myself say vaccinated there
in the background um
let's see what else we got hey david uh
first time caller long time listener i
just had a thought today while i was
mowing lawns and my work and
i was wondering do you have any
philosophical views
that conflict with perhaps
political views that you have no for
example like
i personally think that uh
my social view on say abortion
is anybody should have the right to
choose to do whatever they want
yet my philosophical view on people's
potential is
anyone can become anything and a lot of
the
greatest people on earth come from
hardships and oh man okay all right so
that's going on
uh okay let's continue here's a nine
minute voicemail if you can believe it
hi david my name is adam i just want to
say first and foremost that
i'm standing your show i guess that's
why i'm calling in the first place
uh i do like uh i like your your banter
i like
your points of view i i think that
you're very rational
um and a time where rationale is hard to
find
um i mean i wouldn't con i would prefer
if you didn't
uh put this on your show oh okay all
right well then there were two
follow-ups to that um my message was too
long so
this is adam again yep and then again
this is part three of my message i will
finish it i'm so sorry it's like why
why leave nine minutes and say don't use
it on the show like what
what am i doing i'm just listening to
these on my spare time it's
come on guys please please i'm begging
i'm begging uh
okay let's listen to
a couple more as you already know
being someone who teaches journalism and
it was a journalist yourself in a way
in a way it's always about following the
money
and that is especially true when you
want to understand the motivations of
republicans
they're pretty goddamn transparent this
is not rocket science
what the republicans are simply doing is
getting ahead
of what is going to be a disastrous
story with regards to casualties
from covet they know it they see the
writing on the wall they're not dumb
in that regard they keep oppressive
stuff just like left-wing reporters do
except when it comes to getting on
camera then they figure out ways to spin
and lie their way
and gaslight people but they realize
that they can't keep doing that this is
the guy who liked fidel castro in a
previous voicemail
um okay so we got that
um let's listen to
let's listen to a couple more i guess
hello david my name is natalie and i'm
sorry i speak french but i will do
my best to ask my question in english
my question is if lis cheney decide to
become
a democrat members is this going to be
number 51 and then no she's a member of
congress not a senator
so it would not that she's not in the
senate
so that wouldn't um that wouldn't that
wouldn't make a difference
um let's see
here's the eggman still mad that i'm
empathetic
to people that get sick even though
they're anti-vaxx
hey dave you have no empathy at all for
people
that have a gender reveal party and
accidentally
murdered one firefighter and burned down
a part of california no empathy at all
but yet you have empathy
for people that refuse to get vaccinated
believe anti-semitic conspiracy lies
about a vaccine
and kill each other how do you decide
who gets your empathy and who doesn't
get your empathy
by the way i have more empathy for those
morons who burn down california
those are accidents than i have for the
people that are not
vaccinated and dying because that's on
purpose um
shalom brother all right shalom uh
the eggman shot out of a cannon i mean
just completely shot out of a cannon
uh let's see any other voice oh oh i do
want to say thanks to malfunction 99 as
well as
tobe zee meg dog
regnera for signing up via twitch prime
that puts us at 24. also people
continuing to dump in memberships on the
website jack mcallen signing up with the
code myhippa appreciate that
deborah kennedy signing up with the code
myhipa
and kyle nichols signing up full price
kyle wow
numbers 25 26 and 27 you can sign up at
joinpakman.com the spelling of the
coupon code is above my head
let's do a few other super chats and
then we will get back to voicemails
you're the best progressive journalist
on youtube cheers from romania i
appreciate that but i'm really not a
journalist i'm a commentator
important david thank you for addressing
the other covet zero extremists the
people who somehow think we're back at
square one despite vaccines
put on a t-shirt david pakman a
journalist in a way
yes
for having to correct my prior super
chat thank you
thank you matthew i appreciate it
all right a couple of other uh super
chats here
oh here's something about gender reveal
parties speaking of
hey david i just uh heard your bit on
gender reveal parties and and i agree
that uh
you know they're dangerous it's crazy
we're having all these insane fires
whoa hold on here we go
let's go over here very strong
announcement joe biden
safely masked again good afternoon
today i want to talk to you about cover
19.
maybe the best way to start is in a
significant part of the country you
wouldn't have to take one of these off
maybe the best way to start is in a
significant part of the country you
wouldn't have to take one of these off
you don't have to put one on
right like in my home state of delaware
where i live in newcastle county where i
was yesterday in pennsylvania
pensa because people got vaccinated
they got vaccinated they don't
majority of the vast majority people got
vaccinated
look i want to talk about what's really
happening
what it means what it doesn't mean and
what we need to do
this week in the months ahead from the
moment
i was elected i said i'd always give it
to you straight from the shoulder
and we need some straight talk right now
yeah
because there's a lot of fear and
misinformation in the country that's a
bunch of my work
with facts with science with the truth
so what's really happening today
after months and months of cases going
down we're seeing a spike in covet cases
they're going up
why because of this new form this new
variant called the delta variant this is
a much different variant than the one we
dealt with previously
it's highly transmissible and it's
causing a new wave of cases and those
are not vaccinated
our experts tell me that cases will go
up further before they start to come
back down
but while cases are on the rise they're
not we're not likely to see according to
experts
a comparable rise in hospitalizations or
deaths in most areas of the country
so you have to ask yourself why is that
because
164 million americans
are fully vaccinated including
80 percent of the most vulnerable are
seniors
so there's a challenge as you knew there
could be
but there's also good news we've spent
the last six months preparing for this
possibility
the vaccines are highly effective we
have enough vaccine
for everyone to get vaccinated and
thanks to the american rescue plan
and the hard work of the american people
we've administered over
325 million vaccinations
doses in the past six months
we have the tools to prevent this new
wave of covet from shutting down our
businesses
our schools our society as we saw happen
last year
i've said from the beginning that we
will be guided by the science
so here's what the science tells us on
tuesday
the center for disease control and
prevention the cdc
announced its new mass recommendation in
parts of the country where covet cases
are substantially higher where people
didn't get vaccinated
which they define as 50 new cases
for every 100 000 people in a week
the cdc recommends you wear a mask when
you're in public
and indoors like work or in a grocery
store
that's true for both the vaccinated and
the unvaccinated why
because even if you've been fully
vaccinated and
it from severe illness from covet 19 you
could have the delta variant in your
system
and spread it to someone who isn't
vaccinated
we need to wear a mask to protect each
other and to stop the rapid spread of
this virus
as we work to get more people vaccinated
right
and i hope all americans who live in
areas with substantial or high cases
rates
will follow the mass guidance that's
being laid down by the cdc i certainly
will and i have because this is one of
those areas in washington
and my decision my direction
all federal personnel and visitors
to federal buildings will have to do the
same thing
wow as i said from the beginning a mask
is not a political statement
it's about protecting yourself and
protecting others
masking is one defense against the
spread of covet 19.
but make no mistake vaccines
are the best defense against you getting
severely ill from covet 19.
the very best defense
and you want to know how we put this
virus behind us
yeah well i'll tell you how we need to
get more people vaccinated
look and it's important to understand
what vaccines do
and what they don't do put simply
the vaccines are designed to save lives
and prevent
severe illness they're highly effective
at both
190 million americans have had at least
one shot
of that group about 90 percent are done
now
and 10 are waiting for the second shot
to those folks who have one shot but not
the second
go get the second shot even if you're
overdue for the second shot it's not
too late go get the second shot
now now the bottom line is if you're
fully vaccinated
you're highly protected from covet 19.
super strong
but i also know that many of you who are
vaccinated are concerned about what's
called
breakthrough cases yep yes some fully
vaccinated people will still
test positive and some will show some
symptoms of cova-19 that's expected with
almost every vaccine there is
for other diseases but breakthrough
cases remain
rare and almost all are mild cases
in fact virtually all hospitalizations
and deaths
are among the unvaccinated
i also know many of you are wondering if
you need a booster shot to add another
participant today please as of now
my medical advisors say the answer is no
no america needs a booster now but
if the science tells us there's a need
for boosters
then that's something we'll do and we've
purchased the supply
all the supply we need to be ready if
that was called for
folks the truth is as more people get
vaccinated
we are better protected as a nation to
continue reopening safely and
responsibly
we are not fully out of the woods yet
because what is happening in america
right now is a pandemic
a pandemic of the unvaccinated let me
say that again
it's a pandemic of the unvaccinated
there are about 90 million americans who
are eligible to get
at the shot but haven't gotten it yet
as i just mentioned nearly all the cases
hospitalizations and deaths due to covet
19 today
are from unvaccinated people
last month a study showed that over 99
of covet 19 deaths
have been among the unvaccinated
99 percent this is american tragedy
people are dying and will die who don't
have to die
if you're out there unvaccinated you
don't have to die
read the news you'll see stories about
unvaccinated patients in hospitals
as they're lying in bed dying from covet
19 they're asking doc
can i get the vaccine
the doctors have to say sorry
it's too late
right now too many people are dying
or watching someone they love dying and
saying
if i just got vaccinated
if i just it's heartbreaking
and it's complicated even more because
it's preventable
america is divided between the majority
of
eligible people who are vaccinated and
those who are not
and i understand that many of you in the
majority are frustrated
with the consequences of the failure of
the minority to get vaccinated
but i want you to know i'm going to
continue to do everything i can to
encourage the unvaccinated to get
vaccinated
that includes addressing hesitancy and
misinformation
head-on for example i know some of you
are
who are unvaccinated think the
development of vaccine was rushed
therefore
i'm not going to take a chance as a
result i think it's not safe because it
was rushed
i understand but let me explain
our top scientists the national
institute of health the nih
and across the country got to work
applying
decades of research decades of research
let me repeat that decades this is
really great that he's doing this stuff
but these
explanations have to be repeated by
people republicans trust too that's the
thing
in the last six months more than 325
million doses of the vaccine have been
administered in the united states
and billions of doses
administered around the world
the vaccine was developed and authorized
under a republican administration
and it's been distributed and
administered under a democratic
administration
the vaccines are safe highly effective
there's nothing political about them
look at all the people who took a shot
at it
they later relearned a lot of them are
already been vaccinated
from the start i have to compliment
republican senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell
he had made it political he's encouraged
people to get vaccinated as in
continuing to do so and the state's in
pretty good shape
alabama republican governor k.i.v
right recently spoke out to encourage
vaccination
and even the commentators on facts who
have been belittling this for a long
time
some haven't but many have are arguing
get vaccinated
look this is not about red states and
blue states
it's literally about life and death
that's true although we can't ignore
that the case growth in red
counties is twice as high as in blue
counties that's a real thing talk about
freedom
but i learned growing up in school and
my parents
with freedom comes responsibility
your decision to be unvaccinated impacts
someone else
unvaccinated people spread the virus
they get sick and fill up our hospitals
and that means if someone else has a
heart attack
or breaks a hip there may not be a
hospital bed
for them if you're unvaccinated
you put your doctor and nurses at risk
the same frontline essential workers who
put their lives on the line
over the past year and have gone through
hell
with freedom comes responsibility
so please exercise responsible judgment
get vaccinated for yourself
for the people you love for your country
i'm being literal when i say this as i
travel the world almost every day a
foreign leader calls me
asking can i provide his or her country
more vaccines right
where people are desperate for vaccines
people here like nah
doing everything to answer those calls
we're sending millions of vaccines to
people around the world
but folks it's an american blessing that
we have vaccines for each and every
american
we've made it our first and top priority
to have available vaccines for every
elderly american
and that's never going to change as long
as i'm here
that's a shame and it's just such a
shame to squander that blessing
that's why after six months of
extraordinary work and effort
today i'm laying out additional steps
here we go
we should be taking to deliver these
life-saving vaccines to more america
here we go first
we're going to provide more incentives
to encourage unvaccinated americans to
get vaccinated
do it that starts with paid leave to get
the shot
we're still hearing that people are
unable to get time off from their
employer to get vaccinated
well this is unacceptable for some time
now
i've said you should be able to get the
shot and still get paid
thanks to the american rescue plan the
federal government is fully reimbursing
any small or medium-sized business that
provides workers with paid time off to
get vaccinated
employers this costs you nothing
if you haven't given employees paid i
would be willing to donate
a million david pakman show memberships
at a really discounted rate if the
government wants to buy them and then
just hand them out to people as
incentives
government will now reimburse those
employers
to give their staffs who give their
staffs time off
not only get themselves vaccinated but
also to get their family members
vaccinated
that means employers can get reimbursed
if they give
parents time off with paid time
paid leave to take their kids or their
own parents to get vaccinated
so i'm calling all employees across the
country to give
paid time off to get the shot or to help
a family member do so
i promise you it'll cost you the
employer nothing
you'll be reimbursed right secondly
i'm announcing that we'll continue the
work was to work with states
to encourage unvaccinated people to get
vaccinated
in february the grocery store chain
krogers offered 100
to their associates if they would get
vaccinated
and it worked vaccination rates move up
from 50
50 to 75 percent among their employees
states like new mexico ohio and colorado
are offering similar incentive programs
that have helped increase vaccination
rates new york city now too so today
i'm calling on all states and local
governments to use funding they have
received including
from the american rescue plan to give
100
to anyone who gets fully vaccinated nice
i know the pain people get vaccinated it
might sound unfair to folks who've
gotten vaccinated already no i'm fine
with it
but here's the deal if incentives help
us
beat this virus i believe we should use
them
we all benefit if we can get more people
vaccinated
but in addition to providing incentives
to encourage vaccination
it's time to impose requirements on key
groups
to make sure they're vaccinated excuse
me
just this week we took an important step
to protect our veterans
like many civilian hospital systems are
doing the department of veterans affairs
will now require covet 19 vaccines for
doctors and nurses and other health care
workers who provide
medical care for our veterans we must do
everything possible to protect our
veterans from getting coveted
when they come to get medical care they
so
richly earn serving their country here
we go we owe them
next since many vaccinations are
required for active duty military today
i'm asking the defense department to
look into how and when they will add
covet 19 to the list of vaccinations our
armed forces
must get our men and women in uniform
who protect this country from grave
threats should be protected as much as
possible from getting covet 19.
i think this is particularly important
because our troops serve in places
throughout the world
many wear vaccination rates are low and
disease is prevalent
next every federal government employee
will be asked to attest to their
vaccination status
wow anyone who does not attest
or is not vaccinated will be required to
mask no matter where they work but
that's my
hipaa times a week to see if they've
they've
acquired covet socially distance
and generally will not be allowed to
travel for work
likewise today i'm directing my
administration to take steps to apply
similar standards to all
federal contractors wow if you want to
do business with the federal government
get your workers vaccinated
look at the chamber of commerce
representing
tens of thousands of american businesses
the national association of
manufacturers
the business roundtable which comprises
of the largest and biggest corporations
in america they're all applauding the
actions the federal government is taking
and urge
them to follow suit i also commend the
national football league
it has announced that if there are
outbreaks among unvaccinated players and
personnel
then the team risks forfeiting games
urge other sport leagues at every level
to take every step they can
every day more businesses are
implementing their own vaccine mandates
and the justice department has made it
clear
that it is legal to require covert 19
vaccines
we all want our i don't know but he's
he's doing stuff
right i mean like he's trying he's
actually trying to get this done
we'll make that happen more quickly and
more successfully
we all know that in our gut with
incentives and mandates
we can make a huge difference and save a
lot of lives
i also want to speak to families with
children in
we can and we must open schools this
fall full-time
wow it's better for our children's
mental and emotional well-being
and we can't afford another year out of
the classroom
every school should be open and we're
giving them the tools to be able to do
so safely
even in those areas where they have a
higher vaccination they they have a
higher rate of cobit
through the american rescue plan we
provided schools billions of dollars to
implement safety measures
better ventilation social distances and
other measures
in march when vaccinations were scarce
i prioritized teachers and school
workers by utilizing our federal
pharmacy program
almost 90 percent of educators and
school staff are now vaccinated
additionally the cdc has provided
clear guidance how all schools can
safely protect the kids and bring them
back to the classroom
every student wear a mask it's that
simple
so we funded safety measures in schools
we've vaccinated teachers and staff and
we can mask up our kids for further
protection
but once again there's one more thing we
need to do
get more adolescents ages 12 and up
vaccinated now that they've been cleared
in the past week the good news we've
seen
the average number of 12 to 17 year olds
getting vaccinated
go increase 22 per day
yep today i'm asking school districts to
host
one last pop-up vaccination clinic over
the coming weeks
for kids ages 12 and up we're directing
the federal pharmacy
program to help make that happen parents
get your children vaccinated you do it
for so many other things right now
for kids under 12 if and when the
vaccines are deemed safe for them
we'll be prepared to get the vaccines
administered as quickly and safely as
possible
look and as we work to vaccinate more
americans
we're prepared for outbreaks in areas
where there are unvaccinated people
my administration has made it clear to
every governor
that more federal resources are
available to them
this includes deployment of surge teams
composed of experts from the cdc and the
federal emergency management agency
if i were a governor i would be getting
everybody vaccinated
just to avoid surge teams coming to my
state and taking up my time i mean
really like who
if you're a governor why even want to
deal with that just get people
vaccinated
to stem the surge of the virus among
young vets
unvaccinated the pictures of hospitals
in several states overloaded with
patients is unnecessary
avoidable and tragic
you know we'll help any health system
overloaded and unable to cope with a
spike in cases
we're ready to do that let me close with
this
if you're at home and vaccinated but
anxious
or even angry or if you're at home and
unvaccinated
unbothered and unconvinced let's step
back and see where we are
just remember how we've emerged from a
dark winter into a hopeful spring and
summer
but really remember just how dark that
winter was
over 3 600 americans were dying
each and every day
and now even with the surge among the
unvaccinated
we're down to that 300 americans a day
significant millions of people were out
of work
out of homes out of hope and going
hungry
remember those long lines people in
their automobiles waiting for a box of
food to be put in their trunk
experts in pundits said we couldn't get
the vaccines
and if we could get the vaccines we
couldn't get in people's arms and
couldn't get them vaccinated
they predicted our economy would
collapse
remember how we stayed focused and how
we went to work
in six months we got 164 million
americans fully vaccinated
because we vaccinated so many people put
in place so many safety measures
and got economic help to businesses and
people most in need
our economy is recovering more than 3
million americans are back to work since
i was sworn in
a faster job growth than any previous
administration any
we're experiencing the fastest economic
growth in nearly four decades
the best in the world as of now
in fact today's gdp numbers show that
the first half
of the year our economy grew faster than
any point in nearly 40 years
our economy grew more in six months
than most wall street forecasters
expected for the entire year before we
implemented our plan
and just yesterday we announced a
bipartisan infrastructure deal
that's going to continue this momentum
over the long term by making the most
significant investment
to rebuild america in nearly a century
but we still have to face many
challenges we still have a lot of work
to do
as we readjust to a post-pandemic
economy
but we have the right plan right we're
coming back
we just have to stay ahead of this virus
i know this is hard to hear i know it's
frustrating
i know it's exhausting to think we're
still in this fight
and i know we hope this would be a
simple straightforward line
without problems or new challenges but
that isn't real life
we're coming out of the worst public
health crisis in 100 years
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
as i told you before i carry a card in
my pocket i hope i have it with me
i have a carry card in my pocket with a
number of americans dead from covet 19.
as of today this morning the total
deaths in the united states were 609
441.
granted the death rate per day is way
down it's down to 400 about
dead but that's more deaths
than world war one world war ii
vietnam 911
iraq and afghanistan wars combined
this is as tough as it gets and we're
americans
when we get knocked down we get back up
that's who we are that's what we do
that's why there's no nation on earth
like us
and we're prepared like never before we
have the tools
to save lives to keep our economy
growing and growing
and going after the past six months
following the science we know we can
dramatically lower the cases in this
country
we can do this we brought our economy
back to life and we kept it going
we know we can send our kids back to
school
we know we can beat this virus we can do
this
we all just have to do our part
my fellow americans this nation has
never failed
we have come together as the united
states of america
so i say to all those who are
unvaccinated please
please get vaccinated right and the rest
of america
this is no time to be despondent or let
our god
our guard down we just need to finish
the job
with science with facts with the truth
and together as americans we're going to
be able to beat this
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops thank you
mr president
how long do you think it might be
necessary to wear a mask and at one
point you think people might have to
have a booster shot
i said in my talk the booster shot is
not needed now it is possible
that it will be needed later i don't
know they don't the
science hasn't dictated he already
addressed that and the
first part of your question i think
people might have to wear a mask again
well if you notice a lot of places
people don't have to wear masks
let's get that straight the places where
people have gotten
vaccinated where we have a high
vaccination rate people do not have to
wear a mask at all
like some of you were with me yesterday
when i was up in uh
lehigh valley didn't have to wear a mask
there don't have to mask if you come
home to delaware with me i know you love
doing that
uh but you don't have to wear a mask the
places
people are probably gonna have to wear
masks
in those communities where
the high rate of unvaccinated stays high
and they don't move they don't move to
getting vaccinated
but i think you're going to find the
patients of businesses
and the patients of a lot of other
people running thin right
because the fact is if you had
high vaccination rates you we wouldn't
be in this spot right now
yes mr president will this
set up an american workplace for federal
workers and
private sector that really is the
vaccinated versus the unvaccinated
and is that a pressure you're trying to
harness now well
no i'm not look what i'm trying to do is
keep people safe
i mean that sincerely so right i mean
the thing is
anybody for free can get into the
vaccinated group vaccinated
you present a problem to yourself
to your family and to those with whom
you work
because as pointed out i was asked the
question about why would people who have
already been vaccinated get it
well you got anywhere from two to three
percent
on average the last study done
that can still get coveted
they don't get very sick they don't get
hospitalized it's not serious
but they can catch it and the concern is
they may be able to pass it on right
and so that's all being studied right
now
but it's the important thing is if
people are vaccinated
the transmission rate drops through the
floor
and that's all we're trying to do yes
thank you why not um push for vaccine
mandates in states
private companies schools do you want to
see those entities
pass vaccine mandates well i i'd like to
see them continue to move in that
direction
and that's why i pointed out i had asked
the justice department to determine
whether that is
they're able to do that legally and they
can
local communities can do that local
businesses can do that
it's still a question whether the
federal government can mandate the whole
country
i don't know that yet
[Applause]
earlier this week that we are not headed
back towards lockdowns but if the
science is evolving
how can you be so confident in that you
heard we heard you say weeks ago
that the virus was on the run but dr
fauci has also indicated that we are
headed in the wrong direction
well you're
literally correct on everything you said
but it doesn't make
come to the conclusion you're implying
it is
clear that if everybody's vaccinated the
existing
vaccines work to prevent death serious
illness hospitalization
okay if ever so if tomorrow i could wave
one and every american
was vaccinated then in fact we'd be out
of the woods
now can something else happen a year
from now can there be a different virus
can there be some
that's possible but i'm talking about
coven and the existing variants have
come forward so far
so it makes a it's a simple proposition
if you're vaccinated you find yourself
in a situation where
you are highly unlikely even if you
somehow get the virus very small
percentage do
that you are not going to be
hospitalized you're not going to be on a
ventilator
you're not going to be sick but you
could be in a position to possibly
spread it to someone who wasn't if you
have it in you
yes thank you so much mr president thank
you um i wanted to ask
why not um require that the people
show proof that they're vaccinated and
also if you could just
with the four million how much of an
impact do you think this will have
do you have a projection so
a projection on what how many people
will get vaccinated by putting in this
system
no i'm not going to get in the business
of projecting i
uh exactly how many people are likely
all i know is that
we go through these periods then we run
up against a wall
then something happens where people
realize oh my lord this is really a
problem and
they begin to see things look the fact
that uh
um a lot of your friends are now saying
get vaccinated
who were before we're saying that's not
a problem this is all a democratic thing
with a small d and a capital d i mean
there's a lot changing
right people are becoming aware the more
aware they become then we have these
surges of people going out and getting
vaccinated
and it just keeps building i'm sorry
what about what
we're not requiring proof sir
well that is there's two ways to do it
um and i think you're going to see
some institutions doing that like you're
going to fly abroad you got to you're
going to have to
have proof you're not just going to be
able to say yeah i got tested
you got to provide proof my guess is if
we don't start to make more progress a
lot of businesses and a lot of
enterprises are going to require proof
for you to be able to participate i
would assume so
mr president take off shortly here
what further actions are you going to
take to encourage private businesses to
follow this type of model to either
require
vaccines or require testing or other
preventative procedures
i just did i'm going to keep at it i'm
going to be talking about it around
isn't that what this whole speech was
about to
reach out to private businesses meet
with them try and actively encourage
them to follow this model
well i have that's why we have folks
from the every from the chamber of
commerce
fractures etc so you know i am
am i going to call a meeting of every
you know business in the country to come
to washington
or go on i have made the case repeatedly
it's a really strange it's like this is
an event where joe biden lays out what
he's going to do to encourage business
and then the woman's like what what are
you gonna do about encouraging
like that's what the speech was about i
just gave the speech demonstrated you
can't prove you've been vaccinated
you have to be tested
secretary austin said he was already
considering mandating the vaccine
after it was fully approved would you
like to see the mandate going to effect
before cool approval and do you think
he's open to that
i know he's open to it and the question
is
when is the right time to get the most
bang for the buck when you do it a lot
of this is timing
and so i think it's going to happen but
i look
the one thing that you all are being
politely and
appropriately referencing is that it's
still a temporary approval
so when does the final approval come it
usually takes
a lot of a lot of work to to get there
i made a commitment i would not tell
anyone in the justice department who
they should prosecute and i would not
tell the health industry they assume the
government health
entities what they should say and do but
my expectation is they're going to reach
that conclusion
in the early fall thank you very
[Applause]
you much if you were fully vaccinated
you no longer need to wear
a mask and it seems
that's peter ducey
[Music]
that getting vaccinated made a gigantic
difference
and what happened was new bearing came
along
they didn't get vaccinated it was spread
more rapidly
and people more people were getting sick
how frustrated are you with those people
oh man uh all right so very very
different than when trump would speak
about kovid
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something like that
by injection inside or closing we hit
the body
with a tremendous uh very powerful light
apply light and heat to
cure supposing you brought the light
inside the body
donate plasma and donate plasma today
plasma okay so as you know a very very
different event than what we saw
uh from a former president donald trump
i have just been given an emergency new
song from jethro bradley my bag of
mangoes
up under trump cost me eight dollars i
love mangoes too
nine cents okay now that we are
up under our biden's regime my bag of
mangoes now costs
11.99
my bag of mangoes my bag
my bag of mangoes my bad
i like it
[Music]
[Music]
that seems like a pretty good deal
aren't mangoes like three bucks each
[Music]
[Music]
bag
[Music]
raise the price of fruit don't you want
me to be
healthy don't you
[Music]
don't i raise the price of fruit don't
you want me to be
healthy healthy
[Music]
mangos back down all right so a super
strong submission from jethro bradley
i want to thank everybody for joining me
it's been another
historic stream an historic day
there will be more that i can promise
you
[Music]
if you're thinking about joining the
david
pakman show he's got a lot of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add
his name
at the end of the subject
[Music]
he'll hit you with some facts
empirical at that
and once or twice a week he'll men